welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast you know who it is by now if you
if you're this deep into it you you're
on board with it you're one of the
members who joins us every single week
to check out the podcast we love you
guys as always I'm your host Paul from
heavy spoilers joined by none other than
Greg from real rejects Greg how's it
going it's quite positive week again
I've got some good news good feelings
about it this time let's go we got good
feelings today Paulson we got good
feelings and by the way if you guys
listen to us on Apple and Spotify please
rate this video video or audio whatever
it may be helps us out in the long run
um but I'm excited man you sent me the
breakdown for today and it's mostly good
news it's making me feel a little empty
on the inside I feed off the negativity
but too much good news today too much
good news giv to your anger SE your
feelings so yeah um weekend box office
domestic we're starting off on a bit of
an bit of a negative note but we've got
the top three yeah we've got the top
three domestic box office numbers here
Paw Patrol 2 has coming at 23 million
sawx at 18 million and the Creator at 14
million which it's not very good um I
did kind of feel like the Creator was
going to be a bit of a flop but I really
enjoyed the movie um I was hoping that
it would get good word of mouth I was
telling people yeah go see it please go
see it because the thing is Greg I see
the same comments popping up on every
single video that we do whenever we of a
Marvel or Star Wars or something that's
more of a franchise based thing you
always get the Hollywood's crap now
nothing's original it's just the same
old sequels and reboots over and over
and then we get given this original
story original sci-fi no one goes to see
it so you get what you deserve guys you
get what you deserve you've got to go
support this stuff when it comes out so
yeah 14 million and why do you think it
didn't do that well I mean I I saw the
trailers on my own time and I I like the
trailers like it looked visually
appealing but it is one of those cases
where I can even see why it might not
have done well um from like a lot of
people chalk it up to oh it's not an own
IP or anything like that but at the same
time you know some people have have told
me that oh there's there's visual
elements that remind me of things like
Blade Runner 2049 or or the original
Blade Runner for that matter and you
would know better than I would in that
regard but even a movie like Blade
Runner 2049 ultimately they didn't do
all that well and sure maybe because
it's not an original Ip H but I feel
like they really I mean maybe because
it's an original it's not like based off
of some you know pre-established IP at
the same time I feel like they really
pushed the marketing on this one they
were they were gung-ho about it um but
perhaps there was something emotionally
tangible that was not able to truly sell
us on the experience overall and when
you think about the what makes something
truly original there was a lot of things
that I felt people were saying was oh
it's it reminds them of this it reminds
them of this it reminds them of that so
maybe even perhaps the the the thing
that's being talked about all the time
is this is a really expensive like 80
million film and it was it's an original
film at the same time perhaps what makes
it truly original was not the thing that
was being sold to audiences at the end
of the day um I get their names confused
which Gareth is it is it the Edwards or
Evans I forget which one it is one of
them the one who did not do the raid uh
that Gareth guy he's not as well known
as a director like if you put Nolan's
name on this sure it probably would have
done better uh but you know we're not in
1999 anymore whenever the Matrix came
out where you can have a totally
original looking sci-fi film where you
don't need a huge director's name at the
same time that had Keana Reeves and John
David Washington is not as big of a box
office you know star or box office pole
so I can see how there's a lot of
factors ultimately working against it
it's not a pre-existing IP the trailers
themselves while really good and
probably speak to film enthusiasts or
ciles uh ultimately are not reaching
audiences that are not within that
specific
category and it's a bummer because
everyone I know that Cena actually
really enjoys it even though that it's
not you know void of its criticisms
everyone I know that has really enjoyed
it you included as well but what do you
think it flopped um I think sci-fi in
general really has an uphill struggle at
the box office it's very rare that you
see a completely original Ip sci-fi film
do really really well and a lot of times
well more often than not those movies
tend to flop because I was thinking
today like Terminator did really well
Avatar obviously massive thing but then
you've got these sort of scattered films
in between that like your contacts um
obviously the Matrix did really well
but like arrival like that yeah yeah
they always kind of underperform um and
yeah it's weird seeing it because
they'll get good reviews they'll get
good word of mouth but for some reason
General audiences just don't ever go out
and see them and these films tend to
pick up great um followings once they
hit home release um so I'm thinking
that's what will happen with this it was
shot on a very modest budget it was 80
million I think it looks absolutely I
mean this is obviously I'm parting a lot
of things that have been said over and
over and over about this movie but I
think it looks incredible for its budget
it blows so many other films out the
water especially ones who've seen
released this year and it's kind of
insane to see how good it looks when you
compare it to stuff that has like $300
million budgets um and yeah I'm guess it
just doesn't seem like it connected with
audiences whether it's not you know it
didn't really have you know John David
Washington he's becoming more of a known
name but he's not that household name
that must SE actor that you want to even
tenet didn't have a massive following
behind it and unfortunately yeah um it's
a casualty I think of just the way that
Hollywood's trained people to be ever
since the pandemic you know we've had it
in our minds that if we're not desperate
to go and see a movie it's going to hit
streaming very soon and we can just wait
for it to go on home release and yeah
Studios have kind of shut themselves in
the foot by doing this and it's just the
pandemic just affected behavior and how
audiences view stuff and you know with
sci-fi in general not doing those
massive numbers it it just didn't seem
like a lot of people were feeling like
they really got sold on the film which
is a shame because again it's a really
good movie and I think once it hits at
home releases there's going to be a lot
of people that come around on it and go
oh I'd love to see a sequel to that it's
like well it made no money mate so s is
we're going back to doing Marvel and
Star Wars movies and nothing else for
the next 25 years all the original films
that succeed are because this is like
the big conversation around it is that
it's it's a relatively big like it's a
modest budget considering the kind of
Blockbusters are out there now uh but
it's bigger than a lowbudget film you
know it's it's even it's still above mid
budget range right and when you think
about the original films that still
actually do well it's the horror
category man it's all like that a24
horror or doesn't even have to be a24 uh
but generally it's it it is horror
that's is the the thriving genre and you
get a lot of originality in there and
that seems to be the main the main genre
that actually can still Thrive with orig
with truly original content you know
yeah and we've got the Exorcist believe
are coming out this week I'm like a
crazy Exorcist fan one of the best
movies of all time I think and I'm
excited for it I just no I don't want to
do it and it it's because I'm more
anxious that it's going to be be
terrible um I'm really really worried
that it's going to come out and be like
a modern retelling and and just jump
scares and everything that the original
Exorcist wasn't and I mean the obviously
the original Exorcist had it jump scares
in but this the horror in that's a lot
more subtle and there's a lot of hidden
layers and subliminal things going on
with it and I think from what I've seen
of this it just looks very kind
of possession 101 movies you know what I
mean like the Exorcist kind of set the
standard for those possession movies and
then ever since then they've just kind
of all followed the same sort of
archetype and yeah I feel like it's
going to go in that direction um I will
Pro I'll check it out on streaming but
I'm not rushing out to see it at the
cinema and maybe maybe just give it a
skip I went to Halloween Horror Nights
over the weekend um do you know what
that is no but I'm guessing it's a
Halloween Horror Night yep you nailed it
Paul uh at Universal Studios they they
they basically put together like these
Halloween events events where it's like
it runs from Thursday through Sunday
starting from September to October where
it's it's really it's it's jam-packed
it's super packed every single day and
they put together these mazes like they
had a Last of Us maze which is pretty
cool they had a Chucky one and then they
have Exorcist they have The Exorcist
believer Maze and you really they they
like they like recreate the sets and
it's a lot of like scarers and whatnot
and and a lot of actors and costumes and
makeup and the whole point is you're
walking through it and then they jump
out and scare but you're also getting an
idea of what the movie is because the
idea is sort of submerged like they had
an evil dead rise maze so you know they
going through the apartment the elevator
and all these things to kind of give you
an idea and they and because it's
Universal they really build this stuff
and and they get to use the actual props
and a lot of the actual makeup so it's
very like Hollywood involved and I went
through Exorcist believer and as I was
walking through it and even though it's
supposed to be the ultimate experience
of horror in the the music's blasting
and you got the people in makeup and
they're kind of spoiling some scenes for
you I just found myself with my hands in
my pocket going I'm just not interested
in this movie I thought I would be but
I'm I'm really not excited for it and
then the maze I won't spoil anything of
what they should because part of me was
going I feel like they're kind of
spoiling some really big plot points in
this one maze I'm walking through and
the movie's not even out yet and I'm
going this is a little much this is a
little too much I think they're they're
going a little too big in this movie you
get an you get a good idea of because
like what you were talking about of how
it's being like Possession movie 101 and
a lot of it is within the subtlety of
the dread and the horror and the
psychological Terror and there's like
these monsters that they were that they
had in the Maze I was going and it was
really populating the maze to give you
an idea when I went through last of us
there's a lot of clickers which makes
sense and then here they were really sh
showcasing these monsters
and I was going I don't even recall
these monsters in the trailer but
they're all over this Maze and I feel
like they're overdoing it which got me I
didn't think the maze would be the thing
that really makes me get concerned about
a film yeah I mean it's the 50th
anniversary of The Exorcist this year
which shows its staying power you know
there's not many horror movies that were
made 50 years ago that are still you
know getting sequels and stuff William
friedkin died this year as well and yeah
I I'm just kind of apprehensive about it
it's it's one of those there's been so
many bad Exorcist sequels and prequels
as well I don't know if you know Greg
but um The Exorcist prequel they
actually shot it twice and what happened
was that both star and Stell and scars
God so they made a version of it right
they uh did the whole prequel stuff and
they realized after they'd shut the
entire thing they didn't really like it
that much so they went back reshot the
whole movie from the ground up right and
then released that but then that didn't
get well received so they went back and
got the original thing that they shot
and then released that insane story
honestly this is what happened though
you guys will you go check it out this
is what happened um it was the oh fck I
forgot the names um but yeah there's a
hell of a lot of stuff so there's
Exorcist the beginning um and Dominion
Dominion the prequel to Exorcist h both
pretty much the exact same movie if you
watch them you'll be blown away by and
yeah both were released um but in the
wrong order that they were shot so very
strange story but that's coming this
week um October is going to be a big
month for horror I'm hoping to go out to
the cinema to see some of this stuff but
we're going to have to see we're joined
by a guest here if you guys can see
little cat um so yeah the cat's on board
that's a bit of a creepy thing for
Halloween a bit of a creepy we're gonna
get creepy in the show wait till I get
my black
cat now some good news in the show yeah
the writer strike is over as we reported
last week we we reported it first before
anyone else says but we didn't no
obviously um so the the details of the
the deal that they've struck came out
and for this part of the video we're
going to be breaking down exactly what
was said um and Greg do you want to take
it bit by bit and kind of go through
them this comes from Screen Rant who've
wonderfully put out a list um and number
one point is Hollywood has improved the
shoner training program um so crucially
this is said to be the number one point
the wja have reached an agreement to
renew the
$250,000 in annual funding for the
shunner training program so this is
basically a program that helps creators
and writer producers hone their skills
so that they can become basically
accomplished Professionals in their
field and then go on to you know
basically learn what they've watched
when shadowing other creators and and
run their own show um in the past they
weren't putting that much money into it
and you were kind of creating a sort of
I want to say dead end where people were
coming on board you know writers getting
seeing what was going on but their
contracts would be cut short and ended
at the end of a show and they'd get no
more experience on that wouldn't get
hired for anything else and they just
basically live their life just being
these bottom level people who never had
any chance of promotion or working their
way up to that um so that's a that's a
pretty good solid thing uh is part of
that to compensate for because a lot the
writers really wanted to get rid of the
writers rooms um not the writers rooms
what were those called mini rooms not
the WR they want to get rid of the
writer's rooms they want to get rid of
the mini rooms and they weren't able to
successfully get rid of that but I feel
like this helps alleviate some of the
pain of still having to keep that on
because you get have an extended
contract and you get an opportunity to
at you know really getting the skills
developed so you can be a showrunner one
day which is generally like if you don't
want to become you know a screenwriter
for you know films this is actually one
of the next best things where you can
become like the writer producer head of
IT essentially the Vince Gilligan or the
Tina Fay you know I think that's a
really cool really cool thing yeah
what's the next point the next point if
we're going in the order here
screenwriters they've been secured
improved terms for high budget svod
subscription video on demand so in order
for screenwriters to be able to secure
the fixed domestic and forign residuals
for VOD and svod they needed streaming
data transparency therefore the wga must
now be provided with the total number of
hours a series or featurelength film is
streamed both domestically and
internationally under a confidentiality
agreement meaning the public won't see
it but they can see it uh this includes
certain High budget original series like
stranger things or Wednesday the numbers
for which the wga may share with its
members who will now be paid 100 150% %
premium for original Pilots for high
budget streaming videos on demand and
115% premium for backup scripts this is
so it's it's interesting that they're
going to be able to see it and you have
to become like a really successful
working writer to get this it's it I I
liking it to how like the government
knew about aliens and they couldn't talk
about it we all want to know the
streaming numbers and now the writers
are going to be able to know I think
this is a this is a really big win for
the writers though because if I'm not
mistaken originally Studios were amtp
was going we're not going to show you
jack we don't we're never gonna
show you any of this and now they have
at least conceded to all right we'll
show you but you just got to keep your
mouth shut you know things are going to
get leaked though someone's gonna leak
some stuff when we're going to get some
numbers 100% And I've always theorized
that the reason they have haven't let
this stuff get out is because of how
much it would affect the company stock
for example if they release a big show
you know they say they've got 14 million
viewers on we'll not name any names but
I I like Ahsoka by the way we get
negative I'm just making a joke here 14
that was the most recent show I could
think of um but yeah if it turned out
that wasn't actually the case because
someone leaked the numbers out it would
obviously make people question exactly
what the streaming numbers are and it
could cause negative effects on the
stock so I can see why the Studios have
wanted to keep this Secret in the past
um they obviously know their own
streaming numbers but yeah they've want
to keep this locked down we'll see if it
gets out but at least with the writers
they can have more transparency and
think at least I know I'm not getting
ripped off when I want to get paid so
much but they're also online saying look
how successful this show is and it's
like actually it's not that successful
but they're just doing PR work so that
the company doesn't syn um so yeah
pretty I think that's one of the best
things that they've got out of it to be
honest that's a massive help to them
and yeah and screenwriters point three
screenwriters have a new streaming deal
um so this says one of the biggest
priorities for the wga was finding a way
to have rightest compensation reflect
the success of Wy pop is streaming
serieses like stranger things or
Euphoria H fortunately in addition to
the fixed existing residuals residuals
The Guild established a viewership based
model as well that would reward shows
and thus writers with greater viewership
and Studios agreed I don't actually know
what this means Greg i'm
I was hoping you would explain it man
yeah it's just saying that like Paul's
gonna get this down for me I'm gonna I'm
G he's gonna put it into a language that
Greg's brain can
comprehend I'm what what what's
happening is I'm trying to read it and
make it sound like I know I can read and
then when I'm messing up words I'm Focus
I'm focusing on that thinking oh my God
people listening to the podcast they're
going to think I can't read and they're
going to make F of me they're going to
be writing comments but they I'll not be
able to see them because I can't read
Greg um some what it says as an example
of what that would look like for writers
it would include bonuses like $9,000 for
a half episode on Netflix Amazon or
other major streaming services and
$440,000 for a featurelength film with a
$30 million budget yeah don't know what
any of that means but uh yeah
screenwriters have a new streaming deal
according to that now um sta point four
we we was so point four just before you
get into it this was the big thing that
kind of held up the negotiations last
time oh yeah was still try to read it
and go let me see if I can understand
this a little bit better but it sounds
like they'll get good money if a half
hour show is a success and an hour show
Ison bottom line yeah um Staffing terms
and duration Provisions have improved
for episodic series uh if a series is in
between Seasons or something happens
during in the middle of development
there are now Provisions in the WG wga
contract that ensure writers remain on
television shows affected by the writer
strike a global pandemic or something
else that's good that they're factoring
in another Global pandemic these are in
the form of development rooms AKA preg
green light rooms esta that's what
that's part of what I was trying talking
about earlier development rooms and mini
rooms established before and during the
production of a series their minimum
weekly rate compensation will follow the
nine weeks of work 10 to 19 weeks of
work and 20 plus weeks of work models
and three writers in the room for six or
fewer episodes got it oh okay and five
if there are seven to 12 episodes and
six if there are 13 or more and I think
one thing that's not mentioned here is
that if it's six like there has to be a
a writer producer um like a certain
number of those staff have to be a
writer producer but you can kind of uh
interchange between them so does if
there's like 20 episodes you don't need
to have like I talk about like
showrunner or or the people when they
were say they get paid $111,000 or
whatever um the the article 14 writers
you can you need at least a writer
producer for like two to three or
something like that right if I'm not
mistaken do you remember that Paul you
know information that sounds good I was
trying to contribute to this paragraph
here and I think I did it you've
contributed nothing and the next couple
of points is basically the next point is
screen writers have secured a minimum
writers room size and compensation
structure so again it's kind of tying
into that you'll have a minimum amount
of staff on I can't say minimum this
week you'll have that many amount of
staff on a show that'll help you out you
know if there's a lot of stuff you need
to go through it's not just resting on
one person's shoulder uh the next one is
screenwriters have secured an improved
pay deal which obviously you know if
you're striking it's pretty much 100%
always going to be down to pay dispute
along with this 7 screenwriters will
receive better health insurance and
pension contributions which again is to
be expected in a strike but the most
interesting one I think um even though
I've probably said that for every single
point is that Hollywood's use of AI in
the writing process will be way more
transparent so what they can do now is
that um there were lots of rumors
obviously Greg you know about it that AI
was going to get brought massively into
the way that things were going to be
written going forward and we even saw
during the strike that there were
several job listings for people like AI
person who looks over technician stuff
and it's like 180 Grand a air or
something crazy um and there was that
big worry that AI was basically going to
get brought in to take everyone's jobs
and what would happen was Hollywood
would go with the machine type in some
prompts like make a billion dooll movie
for me and they it pop out a script that
was like Avengers end game too and they
would then hire orer to come in pay them
a basic rate and B BAS basically just go
through the script and correct the
spelling mistakes and be like Oh Tony
Stark's dead H so we can't really use
them and stuff like that now what's
actually happened with his steal is
they've pretty much scrapped I would say
a majority of all the things that AI
would be doing so a writer can now
decide whether they want to use AI or
not I would be like yeah s that I'm
taking the weekend off mate write the
whole script for me know
obviously yeah so any material generate
by AI can't be used to undermine a
writer's credit or be considered Source
material a writer can of their own free
will choose to use AI as a tool provided
by the company as long as the company
consents to this um that being said as
well a company cannot require its
writers to use AI software as part of
their work the company also has to be
upfront with the writers about whether
materials given to them during the
course of their work have been generated
through the use of AI the wga can assert
the exploration of writers materials
particularly to train AI which is
prohibited under law it's crucial that
writers know what's happening to their
material consent to how it's used and
understand where their ideas could be
plagiarized misrepresented and altered
by AI enough to effectively put them out
of business so we basically Greg we've
stopped Skynet before we've basically
stopped Skynet before it all kicks off
now another thing that this kind of ties
into sag's meeting this week I believe
on Wednesday to talk to the atmt pppt
about everything um and judging by how
this Deal's gone I'm guessing
something's going to happen close out of
that now you might remember a couple of
weeks back we talked about how actors
could be brought in scanned given like
$50 and then totally do one and
basically the the studio could use their
their complete body scan as part of
someone in the background of a scene or
an extra or something and never have to
pay them again judging by this it sounds
like they're going to scrap that as well
which I'm hoping because that just puts
so many people out of work but hearing
that AI is is getting shut down and
writers can choose whether to use it or
not they can decide and consent on
whether their Works used and pulled into
AI it sounds bloody great what you
feeling on that Greg it all sounds great
I still think
that it it doesn't feel like it's a I'm
not 100% confident that that the studios
will completely oblige uh I feel like
there's going to be some shady things
that still happen and there's going to
be things the writer's Guild or you know
they're going to be fighting against
that were they're it's so easy to get
away with using Ai and not having to
disclose it you know what I mean because
because it's Ai and it something can be
generative like they could just find out
if you can submit something and you
don't have to disclose it and it's it's
hard to find the paper trail for
something like that you know so I I
still feel like that I don't know I got
my I got my um cautious side of like of
I still think they get Studios might
pull some and not disclose it to
the writers because like one of the
things is you know that if they if they
have an idea if the Studios have an idea
and they want to write and they want to
writer to like they hire someone to
write it um but if the idea was
generated by AI they have to disclose
that
and the the fact that a stu an idea was
generated by AI will might turn off a
writer from wanting to do it just
because of that fact be because like the
the fight and the Divide between Ai and
writer is such a big gap and there's um
it's it's turbulent you know and uh I
think that they I'm basically saying
that I think the Studios have the
capacity to do some AI and feel
like they they don't have to disclose it
you know and that's my big concern about
it like they they buy an office for them
yeah yeah call like Alan Iverson 2 and
it's basically it's like oh who can I
just go meet my colleague in there
haven't met him yet don't go in that
room don't go in that room and one night
they sneak in to see what's going on
it's just a computer with a printer
attached to it just coughing out scripts
very worrying AI I find the Creator kind
of brought me around on it it was like
maybe AI is good and we can all be
friends with it but yeah the fact that
it's just completely putting so many
people out of work I can imagine there's
so many freelance artists that are just
not getting work anymore because
YouTubers in the past would have used
them to do thumbnails and they'll just
instead type in a prompt and get the
exact same thing that looks slightly off
but it is it is improving to be fair um
I think AI is going to get better and
better and it's yeah very unfortunate
how how much work it's going to take
away from people you can get an idea
from Ai and just not copy and paste it
you know you're like oh that's a great
idea all right well I'm just going to
delete this and now I'm going to write
something you know it's really easy to
get away with it yeah that that's why
I'm so glad there's been these
restrictions put in place because I know
I'm sounding quite jovial about it but
it is quite worrying and yeah just
getting a victory over it on that and
you know we'll see what happens these
deals get negotiated every three years
so hopefully they stick to that because
I think Hollywood must realize as well
that by doing this they're killing their
talent pool there's going to be so many
people in 10 years time that haven't
been brought up through the system and
aren't able to produce shows for them at
all and they're just instead
regurgitating all this crap but to be
fair the Creator bombed so maybe they're
just like ah well we're not going to try
anything original anyway now speaking of
un this is going to be the worst segue
ever speaking of an original Loki season
two we got to see episode one don't get
why I even brought that into it I was
trying to come up with a clever way to
go into this but we'll just just forget
I'm an idiot yeah and just go go right
into it so yeah lucky season two Greg we
we got to see episode one I've been very
good I've not watched any of the rest
just watch the first one written my
script done the audio the breakdowns
coming when the the episode releases
very excited to talk about it when this
is out the Embargo will have lifted Greg
what's your thoughts on it Marvel was
back baby I
I loved it uh I really I really love the
hell out of it I rewatched season one
leading into it and um you you put out a
tweet that was talking about how it's
even better as a binge and yeah I kind
of I watched them like one day at a time
uh so I didn't watch it like six hours
straight or something I did watch it one
day at a time and I think I think it
actually was a better experience that
way and I had forgotten just how
freaking amazing Loki actually
is like that was such a a fantastic show
and it still holds up so well and it's
directed really well and one of my
little concerns was the fact that Kate
Heron wasn't returning to direct when I
thought it was one of the rare cases in
Marvel where I could feel a director's
unique Vision around it regarding you
know the camera movement Aesthetics
symmetry all that good stuff that a
director has to come in and formulate
and they brought in the directors the
people who worked on
moonnight and while I liked moonnight
overall I still felt like ah maybe doing
that was because they might be able to
control them or something to that
regard and I gotta say you know stepping
following in the shoes of Loki season
one and Loki season 2 with these new
directors it it was very very like from
the get from the be very beginning
it's a very impressively shot series A
lot of times you talk about with the MCU
of rare is the day where you feel like
there is something truly special in the
way the visuals are done or the
cinematography the camera work and that
was the first thing that really stood
out to me because it's it's darker but
it like mood-wise tonal wise I kind of
got the vibe of I kept liking it to like
a even the way a lot of these long shots
were done of like a 70s sci-fi horror in
a lot of ways and I was very very much
impressed by the way it was shot at
times it looked like it was even
captured on film which there's no way I
like I I doubt it was um but it doesn't
feel like they shot it on a volume it's
not just impressive because of like cool
green screen or visual effects it's all
the in camera work that really generated
a very specific tone that I was just is
so gravitated towards and it is visually
beautiful uh but it's intense great
ticking time clock just that first
episode alone I once I realized I like
oh crap there's only 10 more minutes
left in the episode I I just didn't want
it to end and I really think people are
going to be very happy with this it it
is really really good and it's menacing
it it is what you know it's one thing I
was I was mentioning to you when we were
when I was rewatching it was how
um it brought me back to when when Loki
season 1 ended and they had he who
remains in the setup for the
Multiverse and it was such an ominous
threat and it it got us all jacked for
what the possibilities were and what the
Threat Level was of what's to come after
Loki season one and nothing really lived
up to what they set up even the stuff I
really loved like the properties I loved
in terms of tying it back to what was
set up at the end of Loki season 1
nothing really delivered and especially
Atman quantam Mania did not deliver and
then in the first like 10 minutes of
this it I wish this came earlier because
this is what I wanted after the events
of season one this this was the vibe I
I've been I've been craving you know and
I'm I'm salv at it man I am satiating
more more Loki right now I thought it
was fantastic totally agree completely
agree yeah I was blown away by it you
know I did go back and rewatch Loki and
I just going from that finale into this
um we're not going to do spoilers by the
way guys I know it's heavy spoilers we
might talk about some stuff that's being
you know talked about at like ComicCon
or d23 or events when they've shown it
but beyond that we're not spoiling any
plot points but it has been said
publicly that the the show picks up
immediately after the events of season 1
and it just literally throws you into it
it's such a good moment um the way they
open up you it's got real focus on that
K statue and then it just all kind of
hits the ground running and I was really
Blown Away by it um I think it goes just
beyond just being a sort of I'm I'm not
waving at my camera I'm trying to get to
focus um I I was blown away by how the
camera moves on it throughout it's
difficult when you're reviewing
something to talk about how good
everything is kind of framed and the the
way the cinematography hits and stuff
because it's not something you know when
you come into a review it's normally
talking about the performances and um
part of the story and where it goes but
in terms of just the way the show looks
and the way it moves there's lots of
things that are shut in one take it's
almost like a stage play at part where
the actors coming in and interacting
with it and it's very quippy um it's not
the goofy stupid MCU humor it's all
written as part of the characters and
how they feel naturally it just works so
well like I said we've only SE I've only
seen the first episode I don't know how
much you've watched um but it's yes but
it's it definitely feels like a step up
and it's elevated and I was talking to
you guys about it yesterday saying that
I kind of wish they just ended Loki
season one and then not really released
anything and then dropped this and I
think you know that there's obviously
every week we talk about superhero
fatigue and every like it's such an over
talked about thing um and it's because
of how many mid movies we're getting and
all the projects are kind of ju almost
hit the mark but kind of more tired the
audience out because they know what to
expect by now this just completely blew
me away um really really well acted it's
nonstop and there's lots of really good
twists and turns in it and for the fact
that we almost kind of know where the
MCU is going as well there's still so
much mystery to this like there's a a
scene involving a lift in a character
that they have in it and not a Twist but
something happens and even just little
bits like that you can kind of figure
out what's going on but you're sort of
piecing things together and the way that
they do time travel as well just in this
episode
alone it's it is really really well done
because you've got characters meeting
certain characters in the past that then
affects conversations they have in the
future and then they go back to the past
and have them and you see like a
conversation playing out across two
different time periods just really well
written I I was um really well written
really well directed the MCU is back
we're back to Shilling I was completely
blown away by it yeah and if if this if
the series can keep up this level I
think it's going to be by far the best
Disney Plus show because you know that
Loki that first one was what people
always say it's like oh it's the best
Disney Plus show this is like above that
from what it feels like from the tones
that you get and I think you guys when
you sit down and watch
it like I said it's difficult to
visualize when you're talking about
camera movements and stuff but you'll
sit down and watch it and just the way
you follow through the scenes the first
few minutes you'll know yeah the first
few minutes you'll be like oh W I feel
it yeah going back to that first season
you do kind of realize how static
everything was um but it's just it's
just got such a great flow to it very
Dynamic you can really tell they took
their time in rehearsal and mapped
everything out
and uh this m I don't know if this is a
spoiler but it takes place in the TVA um
and what could happen is that you'd
basically have very boring looking
office rooms corridors and stuff all in
one location where people are just
having conversations and stuff and that
could be
even me describing it there it sounds
boring but they managed to really ignite
the scenes and have them just constantly
popping off because of the way
characters move in their actions and
expressions and the conversations they
yeah it's it's it's brilliant I really
really enjoyed it I can't price it high
enough of that first episode episode two
gonna be one of those Filler episodes
and be oh you you shill you are wrong
you said you said it was good but yeah
brilliant first episode yeah I get what
you're were saying about the sets they
they feel very tangible like they're
Lively but everything feels very
tangible again it doesn't it's
especially with Disney Plus shows they a
lot of times with like the Sci-Fi ones
it can just feel like you're on some big
green screen set and I I rarely get even
the times where it has to be a green
screen set like there's no other
question about it it has to be a big
volume or a green screen it still feels
tangible and it doesn't feel like the
actors are locked off to a small little
location uh the scope of it is very
impressive and it and it's crazy because
as we're talking about it without giving
any details at all it's sounding like oh
do they they do a lot in this episode
yeah they they actually do a lot now
that I think about it there's so much
that happens in the 40 minutes um yet it
doesn't feel over convoluted um it it it
breathes really well and it and it
forces you to to pay ATT ention in a way
that's gripping not just like pay
attention because you got to keep up
with how this is all going it it it is
truly gripping stuff and everything that
worked like Loki and Mobius everything
that worked in the first season that
people loved it just feels magnified
here in a way that feels like a natural
transgression and upgrade uh from the
last one there there are elements to it
that I liken to like Doug Lyman did born
identity and then Paul Greengrass did
the next born movies after that and it's
not exactly that but in terms of like
more refined darker tone feeling more
realistic yet bigger and and heavier
that that's kind of where I would like
in that direction um without it be
because it's even more handheld too than
the first season uh but it's still
smooth yeah I really loved it man I
can't I I I cannot wait to watch the
second episode I I'm am very yeah very
jazzed about what what they're doing
right now yeah and it's quite a small
cast as well when you think about the
amount of people that are in the episode
and like like I said I kind of do liking
it to a stage play where it's very you
know performance and character driven
and yeah it's not much of a a big cast
but just the the way they sell the lines
and the emotion of it kuk Kuan as well
he makes his debut in this episode great
great character very funny comedic
timing is just spot on just kind of seem
seems like like a lost little lamb but
who's kind of being like Oh yeah um so
they do some really fun stuff with him
yeah and I mean obviously he's won his
Oscar and he's done lots of Multiverse
things and whatever but yeah Cayman just
stole stole the show a bit and uh great
new addition to the cast as well yeah
he's got that sincere engaged aloof yet
committed energy uh he's he's the
perfect actor to step into to this world
and you know it coming from everything
every all at once which is a big
Multiverse movie and here it's not the
same performance it's a different
character but the things you love about
about what he brings to a role are are
ever present here I think he's so
perfect he's perfect and and but it's a
good month for superhero stuff man
because we got Jen v as well um which is
also
fantastic that's how you transitioned
Paul that's how you transition that was
perfect I did it it was perfect yeah
that's what I should have done so genv
was uh yeah I've seen episode four
now they've announced that Tech Knight's
going to be in it so I don't feel like
I'm spoiling it by saying that what they
do with tech Knight I'm I'm a big fan of
tech Knight in the comics he doesn't
have much of a big run he has a couple
of issues to himself and they get some
Arc H but I think everybody who's read
the boys they they will remember exactly
what happens in that Arc and it's sort
of his Arc is when it really got going I
feel in the comics um
I think it was about issue seven that he
popped in and up until that point you
know he'd had the crazy wild stuff going
on and ha isn't this funny but during
that Arc you met the legend and then you
also met Tech Knight who had a just wild
thing that happened to him and I think
that he was really when it got on board
and because of that I was a bit
apprehensive about how they were going
to play and I hadn't heard of the actor
before had no idea who he was I had I
wondered how this would fit into a high
School aesthetic and though it's not in
line with the comics what they do with
tech Knight is absolutely brilliant it
is so good um the boys just you know the
boys has always been really creative at
taking the source material pushing it in
a New Direction and they've done this
with tech knite and as soon as you guys
see what he's paring um obviously in the
comics he was a Batman parody they don't
do that but what they have him parody is
just so funny and he's just got you'll
instantly recognize it and what it's
referencing as soon as you see the
scenes and it's just kind of playing
detectives up and stuff and yeah what
they do with them it's brilliant and I
really really enjoyed the episode kind
of has a cliffhanger as well a bit of a
sort of question about what's going on
and it's just another it's another
Banger and I think those first three I
was so apprehensive about the Gen V
falling off and I thought you know
spin-off shows there's very very rare
cases where the spin-off shows as good
as the main one and you know it's early
days at the moment but it definitely
feels like it has the potential there
and those first three episodes I think
were brilliant episode four I think is
brilliant as well really really good
count me in you know Fridays are going
to be a very busy day for me but worth
it because we they're pumping out great
quality with his stuff yeah I think
often times spin-offs especially that
are airing
simultaneously I mean it's like the boy
season 4 is not out yet but we're going
to be getting the boy season 4 sometimes
a spin-off can just feel like the
spin-off and this managed manages to
feel how would I put it I don't think if
you if you watch boy season 3 you need
to watch gen V to watch boy season 4 I I
don't get the impression that's the case
maybe it is at the same time
though I still get I always I
simultaneously have the feeling that
it's it it feels like essential viewing
to me that that's how great I I think
gen V8 actually is it's like the boys
season
3.5 I think the Tone's exactly the same
I think the jokes and humor are the same
the way it's directed and shot feels
exactly the same and you can transition
perfectly into it without it feeling
like it's alien product off doing its
own
thing same time it's very different you
know and and more it's all those things
but also very different at the same time
and I I think that's like the perfect
ground for a spin-off um where you don't
you you feel like you are definitely in
the same world and one thing that really
I mean I've only seen up to episode
three so maybe episode 4 completely undo
the thing element that I found to be
like oh here's why I feel like this is
this might be essential and maybe really
factor into boy season 4 is how um the
end of uh you know like a lot the boys
is often dealing with you know Homeland
uh God I cannot think right now Butcher
and the boys you know trying to take
down um you know the seven and all that
VA seven yeah and here you're dealing
with genv this college and this is where
the supers go through before you can
even get to being part of the seven
essentially right like this is the one
of the essential steps and what and so
while the boys deals a lot with exposing
VA this is dealing with exposing the
stage before that which is the college
and you have your your core characters
which I like the spin on it because you
know the boys often is portraying their
supers as all bad and here you're
getting the impression that this is
before they're all corrupted and maybe
they have an opportunity to become good
supers but it's also showing that
there's other corruption elements that
are happening within you know um go what
is it called gold gulen how do you
pronounce It Whatever the G yeah this is
the part of the podcast where I can't
talk but yeah it's part that there's
they're exposing that stuff and if you
can uproot that like I'm surprised we
haven't had anything if this has always
existed in the universe where you've had
you know Butcher and them try to attack
what goes on at this college because
this feels like such an essential part
of the world of what leads into the
seven and vot uh it's a critical part of
the development and now we're going to
be uprooting the Sinister acts here and
then what happens when you uproot the
Sinister ax at this very essential spot
that even you see characters like Ashley
from vot who are very much involved in
what's happening here at this college
you know so to me it it it feels like
essential viewing it it feels like you
you have to watch this show I I don't
feel like the writers would want to have
you depend on that uh for going into boy
season 4 but I I do get the impression
that you get so much more out of it if
you if you watch this and on top of that
too it's like they they did such a great
job of introducing new characters and
and they're all written so well and it's
layered and it does feel like dark
College mutant High Sky High kind of
deal you know it it feels like the more
the way how the boys has sort of that
more realistic take on the supers and
what they would be like in real life
well what would it be like when aspiring
youth who have superpowers who are also
dealing with the fact that they're aware
of that their parents got greedy and
injected them with this stuff you know
like something with X-Men is the mutants
right and you often deal it with the
youth the mutant Youth and at the end of
the day a lot of times you you you watch
it it's like yeah they have the torture
and soul aspect but so much of the time
when you watch X-Men it's still going
but look how cool it is though it's
still cool yeah there there's Prejudice
stuff happening there's racism stuff
happening and yeah they got some
tortured Soul elements and sometimes
they really just make it all about that
at the same time though you often do go
man that's pretty cool stuff it's still
pretty cool I would still prefer to be a
mutant though because look at all the
cool Powers you get and here they really
do uh the the allegories and the
metaphors they draw between like so I'm
trying to watch my words here for
YouTube the self harm qualities you know
and and the struggles that young
disorder and stuff yeah yeah the way
they draw those parallels and how they
kind of make it a cyclical thing between
like um their powers and how it all ties
in I think it's brilliant they really do
showcase um the things that I feel like
yeah I love X-Men and all that but they
they show you the true darker side to it
where they make they Mak having powers
seem unpleasant and the society they
throw you into that much more unpleasant
as well so while it doesn't have
necessarily that that racism side that
prejudice side that X-Men deals with I
think they they capitalize on something
else that feels more internally sinister
in a lot of ways um so yeah I really
loved it I I really love this a lot I
think I think I got like two very
different comic book based shows that
are airing this month two extremely
different ones and they're both awesome
they're both awesome it's a good
month yeah and then it's followed by
Invincible as well so I it's gon to be a
great couple of weeks um really really
looking forward to it I wish they'd
spread this stuff out more Greg do you
remember September last year it was
literally a different I think in
September it was
like um Rick and Morty Monday Andor
shehulk rings of power and House of the
dragon all in the same we yeah was a
nightmare to work it uh but I it's kind
of hit that point again now where it's
like you've got two amazing superhero
shows like just spread them out through
the air just give a give them a bit of
breathing room because both deserve to
be seen um I think that
that the upcoming episode of genv is one
of the better boys episodes that we've
ever had just because of how good Tech
Knight is and how funny it is he just
completely comes in steals the show and
yeah just a great great performance it's
got a really Sinister side to it but
it's also hilarious and yeah they
they're Masters at this point they know
exactly what they're doing I was
watching a video the other week I can't
remember exactly what it was called so
apologies for not shouting out the
channel but they said that what the boys
can do brilliantly is that it can do all
the stuff that the MCU does really well
but it can also make fun of the stuff
that they do badly so it's not really
falling to the pitfalls that the MCU has
and it's just kind of elevating above
them um and yeah brilliant brilliant
first four episodes I think you guys are
going to love it I think you guys are
going to love Loki as well and yeah I'm
really excited to talk about them I feel
enthusiastic about it for one Greg back
in this superhero stuff really good job
all around guys you should be proud of
yourself let's just hope the DCU can
live up to it he's done it he is the
transition guy this guy
segue I don't call him Segways I call
them Gregs you know what I mean this is
so good right call Paul that was great
James gun he's given some clarity on the
DCU has because obviously everyone's
kind of is it James is it Canon do I
need to go see this one cuz at the start
of the year you said I need to go see it
and I went to see it and it nothing
happened in it James so can of have some
clarity on the the future of the DCU um
so this is what James has said nothing
is in Cannon until Creature Commandos
next year a sort of appeti to the DCU
and then a deeper dive into the universe
with Superman Legacy after that it's a
very human drive to want to understand
everything all the time but I think it's
okay to be confused on what's happening
in the DCU since no one has seen
anything from the DCU yet I don't think
anyone knows what's I don't think you
know what's going on James Warner
Brothers coming every other week and
like this week can you can you go out
and say the flash is the best movie ever
made and Aquaman's 2 is definitely gonna
be important going forward um but yeah
so he said and yes some actors will be
playing characters they've played in
other stories and some plot points might
be consistent with plot points from
dozens of films shows and animated
projects that have come from DC in the
past but nothing is Cannon until CC and
Legacy and then he went went on to
clarify Charo Mar wena will continue
playing Blue Beetle in the DCU as Viola
Davis will Amanda Waller and John Cena
will Peacemaker and they've actually
announced 40 minutes before we press
record Peacemaker 2 is in the works um
so what your thoughts on that Greg what
the hell are you thinking I'm thinking
that he's saying I don't need to watch
Aquaman in the Lost Kingdom so that's a
tank I don't think this
really because everyone's been saying
he's providing Clarity and and at first
you're like okay so it's essentially a
reboot and then he says some other
and you're like but wait a minute now
I'm back to being really confused about
this especially with peace like will
they call it Peacemaker season 2 or are
they going to do um essentially like
a like is Daredevil Born Again Daredevil
season 4 because it sounds like it's not
but it also sounds like it is and I
guess we won't know till it's out right
um is are they GNA kind of do that
method because there's so much about
Peacemaker that was so tied to the
suicide squad which was very much part
of the
dceu and they even have in Peacemaker
season 1 the Justice League cast show up
you know which had Aquaman in The Flash
and all that so to me it if you're just
doing Peacemaker season two it makes it
more confusing and then considering that
Blue Beetle like announcing who's still
going to remain I feel like you can get
away with Viola Davis easily easily to
me that's like a JK Simmons situation
with J Jonah Jameson like yeah she's
perfect as Amanda Waller just keep her
that makes the most sense just keep her
why not but uh cholo and John Cena that
that's the part of it where when you say
stuff like that I just kind of get more
confused because you can't help but
Ponder you might as well like not say
something because then it it just does
throw a wrench in everything that you're
that you're ultimately saying when he's
when he is saying nothing is Canon or is
he is he intending to say that the
cannon will be clear once creature
command
comes out next um next year that's when
you'll understand what we're doing well
Comics have done this in the past you
know the new 52 that's probably the one
in most recent memory where they were
like we're resetting everything but
what's going to happen is we're
basically going to condense every major
story from DC history into a fiveyear
span we're putting that in place so all
of these things like The Killing Joke um
Nightfall just looking at my Comics to
try and remember stuff um
yeah no man's land stuff like that that
all got condensed into a big fiveyear
space and it was said this happens over
that time some of the stuff that you
love and knows Canon some of the stuff
like Batman Shaman that's not Cannon
anymore don't worry about it Batman yeah
one great story not Cannon anymore it's
zero yeah this time and so I think what
they're doing is copying that model
where they're basically taking some
things that worked from the the DCU and
the things that didn't and just saying
don't worry about that mate don't worry
about Shazam 2o we know he didn't see it
personally when it comes to building a
universe though I understand the
principle of it I don't think it's a
good way to take things and I think
what's going to happen is that there's
going to be this black cloud of the DCU
hanging over the DCU going forward
because let's be honest the last four
movies whatever haven't been popular no
one's really bothered seeing them
hardcore fans have but in terms of
General audiences they've not bothered
and people who don't fully get you know
know into this stuff they're just going
to see characters like maybe zachar
Zachary Levi Shazam showing up in
Superman Legacy or something and they're
just going to think it's tied into that
old universe and just be like oh well I
didn't really like that stuff so I'm not
going to bother seeing it I've always
said hard reboot is the way to go when
it comes to films I know a lot of people
are being like well this is how it works
in comics this isn't Comics mate and
it's a totally different medium V the
Cinematic visual medium is so different
It's So Different yeah yeah a comic take
takes like I don't know maybe $500 to
make once you've paid the I don't know
how much inflation's caused it to be but
let's say back in the day you know that
they're very cheap to make in comparison
to a film uh you take a big shot at a
film you Market it cost hundreds of
millions of dollars it's not the same as
just doing a comic book universe and
there needs to be more planning more
thought about how this is going to play
out and just I feel like they're making
the wrong step every step of the way
sure Amanda Waller and so on that they
can can come across but I just don't
think it should be tied to that old
universe and I really do think that hard
reboot is the way to go I feel
passionate about that I feel like that
Meme of Walt from breaking bad when he's
stuck in the Jeep shouting and no one
can hear him I feel like that it's like
how can you not see that that there
isn't the Good Will behind the dceu to
justify bringing that into your new
universe you know it there's not the the
the people in fan base there that are
going to help to catapult it and the
people who aren't fans they're not going
to jump on board because they're just
going to see it as a continuation of the
DCU and just things that they're doing
strategically like starting off with
Creature
Commandos that's not you unfortunately
if you're building a liveaction universe
to me you don't start off with an
animated movie something like
spiderverse sure it's been a great
success but that was never pushed as
being like we're making a Spider-Man
universe
over at Sony it was very much just like
oh he has a little animated Spider-Man
movie oh what it's done well yeah we're
going to make more sequels it's going to
become something and I think just yeah
everything kind of seems like up in the
air at the moment the fact that Aquaman
2 is not even out yet and they're
already coming out and being like
nothing that doesn't matter until
Creature Commandos it's like well yeah I
don't even care that much about Creature
Commandos I'm a big DC fan don't think I
ever read a creature Commando story ever
in my whole life um think it's the wrong
way to start Universe just cut the cord
Let It Go mate it's over he had a you
had an all right run the audience is
telling you they're not interested in
these movies or characters start again
with Superman Legacy and just go from
there stuff will work out a lot better
instead of you trying to retroactively
tie things back into the past and be
like well Wonder Woman 84 throw that
Blu-ray away but keep your Wonder Woman
Blu-ray because that one matters but
just forget that there's a link to Bruce
Wayne from Batman v Superman in and just
throw that away but also throw the Man
of Steel one away because Superman
Legacy is the first one didn't work for
me a lot of people were you know liking
we're trying to liken this you know
speaking about keeping some of it and
then you know erasing others to like the
new 502 right where you had an event and
then after that event Multiverse and
Canon Shenanigans took place and then
now some of this remains and other
things
no the it doesn't sound like they have
an event in place in order to establish
that we a lot of us were under the
impression that it sounded like maybe
that's what the Flash movie was gonna do
yeah that's what they wanted to happen
and I think James Gunn even said some
right I thought in his announcement
he said something that really had us all
think okay then they are doing that that
it's gonna I think he said it's going to
be the reset or something I if I'm not
mistaken yeah to be fair The Flash does
work as a reset you know obviously
brings across George Clooney but it does
change certain things out and alter the
universe slightly slightly some things
are the same some things are changed
just just what James is going for H but
it wasn't a success it was one of the
biggest flops of all time which is so
yeah if you're an executive in Hollywood
you need to start panicking and being
like uh maybe we shouldn't be using this
as a plot
device I I have no idea um I don't know
I think I think unfortunately you know
James gun doing the strategy of saying
none of this matters it's not
working you know hype the MCU sure it's
had its midpoints it's had lots of drops
since end game I mean let's be honest
the MCU yeah has never kind of captured
the the Goodwill maybe to maybe around
no way home um but it's been you know
diminishing returns for a lot of time I
feel like Loki will get good positive
conversations around it
but feige he always tries to sell the
movies are important it's always like
well you know um black widow introducing
the first female Marvel Superhero solo
film The eternals oh this is introducing
the most diverse team and the celestials
are going to be a big thing going
forward you need and there's going to be
some people introducing the post credit
scene shanqi is a very important
character introducing the 10 Rings he's
not out here going oh none of this
matters until Secret Wars mate just s
all this is none of it's Canon what what
do you mean we've got a movie coming out
next month um it feels like they're
trying to build something and even the
Slate that James gun announced it didn't
really feel like it was building up to
something you know what I mean it felt
like they just got some Comics SLA them
down on the ground and we're like oh
that's coming out the authorities coming
out green lanter's coming out it's not
building towards something and I think
just
unfortunately the way the internet is
the conversation with I'm not doing a
hard Rebo it will be stuff like you kept
your wife but you got rid of Henry caval
and I I'm not accusing him of that um
but it will just provide this black
cloud over everything where because
James gun uses his friends and family in
a things they'll see him as scrapping
beloved characters and actors to bring
in people who are just his friends and I
know whenever we bring up that
conversation there'll be people who like
well Martin scor hay works with the same
actors all the time Christopher Nolan
uses the same actors all the time the
difference is that Nolan and scorsi when
they're doing this they're creating
original films with original characters
that people don't necessarily have that
attachment to whereas when you've got a
character like Batman or someone who's
been around in the comics for 30 years
putting your friends and family in it's
going to rub people the wrong way I
think who already have that theory that
James G just casts as friends and family
they're just going to use that to be
like well he's not inventing new
characters for them and I think it it I
just feel like it's going to create such
a black cloud and we know that they're
planning to do 10 years of stuff right
galgadot she's playing Wonder Woman does
galad do really want to be playing
Wonder Woman from 2016 to 2033 or
whatever it you know what I mean it I'm
just screaming at it you know I think
Marvel and DC have recently had this
issue with they want the audience to
meet them where they're at whereas DC
and Marvel they need to meet the
audience where they're at like Echo well
you can tell they're having a nightmare
about that behind the scenes and from
what I've heard just everything that's
happening with it they they're really
just they've hit a point where they're
like we don't even know if we want to
release it it got delayed to January
we've heard rumors that it was
originally however many episodes theyve
even cut one of them they're dropping
all on one day to just rip the Band-Aid
and get it out the way it feels like
they're trying to tell us that that's
what we need to see you know um and that
they're spending all this money on these
projects and it you you're not meeting
the audience You're Expecting The
Audience to come to you because that's
what they love and I just don't feel the
audience love it anymore and I think you
know Loki I think Loki's going to be
successful but coming out and saying
this stuff like oh yeah don't watch that
stuff um yeah we're doing a new thing
just just come see it just it just yeah
it doesn't strike me as the the the
correct strategy to take Everyone's
entitled to their opinion on it
obviously I might be wrong I hope I'm
proven wrong but yeah yeah being a DC
fan sure is tough especially now is is
Creature Commandos a show or a
movie I think it's a show and it's gonna
be like an HBO show is that what they're
doing yeah
no I don't feel like we watch
it I TV
series I don't even know if I will you
know I might binge it um but so it's
going to drop in 2024 it's going to be
part of chapter one Gods and Monsters
and it's going to have Amanda Waller
assembling a Black Ops team called the
Creature
Commandos um yeah
so what like do you think that is going
to capture the audience's imagination
and make everyone jump under the DCU
being like oh I've got to go over to Max
to get things in place I I think it's
just kind of one of those projects where
they're saying it's attached to it but
if you don't watch it you're not going
to get penalized for but not watching it
I mean you have two two camps you gota
you got to win over here probably more
than two because you got your hardcores
who will still even if you're not liking
the DC Universe whatever it is now if
like Shazam and everything that came out
this year even if you're not super into
it but you're still like ah but it's DC
so I'm G to watch it you got that camp
out there of the people who are always
going to go watch it and and then you
got
well the bottom line is he's he needs to
create a sense of unity for audiences
right so maybe Creature Commandos if
that's really great that could win over
the hardcores if the hardcore people who
love DC are like oh wait this is giving
me a good sense of sort of the vibe and
tell but I feel like The Suicide Squad
kind of already like his version of The
Suicide Squad is already giving me an
idea of what a James gun DC Universe
might feel like um and I I love The
Suicide Squad I still think it's a
fantastic film and that's great when I
hear Creature Commandos like it sounds
like animated Suicide Squad to me from
everything that I hear about it uh I'm
I'm sure there'll be differences but
from the initial pitch it sounds like
animated Suicide Squad and and then
Superman Legacy has to be the thing that
goes all right hardcores are going
Creature Commandos is good now it's
Superman Legacy you got to win over
people who haven't given a The
General audiences you got to win over
all those people and you got to win over
um you know the the hardcores as well
and and and then of course you've had
the I don't know how much smaller the
Snider Camp of people who you know cry
out their anguish over what's happened
with you know Zack Snyder Henry caval
and Ben Affleck I don't I don't know
how how much that fervor has
dwindled I wouldn't say it has I still I
mean I
yeah I still see it all the time people
still having an arguments about it I
feel like the DC fan base is just
extremely divided it's in it's in shant
that's what I mean is like the the goal
here has to be create a sense of unity
in some way you know there's going to be
people who are obviously never going to
be happy and and people who might not
ever be able to let
go and I think the
main so the question is will Creature
Commandos Superman Legacy where he's
placing a lot of his cards on here will
that be good enough to win
over all these
people because I think there's there's
more there's room for more confusion to
come down the road admittedly in the
beginning when I first when when we
first announcing the El worlds of of the
DC Universe you know like oh Joker will
be elseworlds like that makes sense I
feel like that was already clear to
people right that that was something
that was uniquely clear to people right
away that that is its own thing and I
think even General audiences understood
that um and then the Batman you know uh
saying that's going to be elor's camp
and then they have other elor's ideas in
mind as well initially that's really
exciting to me but when you think about
how much Batman there have been so
far
will that create some sense of
confusion and if not confusion will it
diminish interest you know in wanting to
see Batman in the DCU when we're already
invested in the Batman via elor's Robert
Patterson Journey you know will will
audiences want to see both truly like
you you know what I mean like that's a
that's the other question I think you
got to ask yourselves like maybe it
isn't a question of like I'm sure
they'll understand but will they be
interested I think like The Flash movie
is is a great example of that they they
leaned so much on Batman in the
marketing for that and people didn't
really care for it and Nostalgia did not
win for it and at that point I was like
man we just saw like Michael Keon we
just saw freaking Robert Pon we had Ben
Affleck now we got Michael Keon here um
and George Clooney and George clo not
forget about the
hor I I think it does get to a point
where
I I am I am a bit I am a bit worried
about that element because I I actually
love the idea of having two separate
Batman of you got Robert Patterson the
Matt Reeves world I think that that
that's awesome a very specific type of
world and and you could have a really
unique Vision that is not tied to you
know some timeline of
continuity versus um the uh versus what
they're going to be doing going with
Batman the Brave and the Bold where you
can get a very different side of Batman
it could probably be feel a little bit
more animated in its own way uh because
he's got the kid there he's got Damen
Wayne with him so there's there's
something that really does excite me
about having both sides of it and that's
the part of me that goes okay maybe
that'll help audiences be interested in
like okay you got the young Batman with
Robert Patterson in a darker more
brooding version and then you got this
other Batman
here
but will they I guess the question is is
will there be too much Batman happening
where people just only want to invest
their time in one so there's there's
room for concern here there is I think
there's reasonable room for concern and
a lot of this is obviously theoretical
we don't really know the answers yet and
James gun keep saying that by the end of
Superman Legacy we should know what's
really going on but yeah I'm really not
really not 100% certain about that yeah
I think think to be fair to James gun to
be completely fair to him he has been
handed a very bad situation where
they're trying to they're still they
were still pushing out four movies on
whilst he was working on a new universe
and I think you know we've seen how
badly the box offices of those have done
I'm sure it was say like just on Shazam
blue Beatle in the flash Warner Brothers
lost about a billion dollars and he's
been handed this thing that's not very
good he's trying to launch out of it and
pull it together and I again I think I'm
I actually go to The Other Extreme of
just going Beyond just doing a hard
reboot I actually think DC need to take
a a chunk of years out like maybe five
years just take a break put a lid on
this universe take some time out regroup
recast and start a fresh once Goodwill's
had time to build back up instead of
just doing what they're doing which is
like going from one failed universe and
trying to almost repair it I I don't
think it's going to work I think it's
such a difficult task and I think more
times than not you're gonna fail and
it's GNA have a worse effect long term
because if this universe crashes then
how big of a break are you going to have
to take before you reboot the next one
right you know you can fail on a one
Universe take time out and and do it
again down the line but if you fail try
and repair it try and build it back up
and that still crashes then it's like
you you're just stuck because it's going
to be so you're going to have to wait
such a long time for audiences to get a
gap where they no longer associate your
films with those two failures to then
build it back up and it's yeah it's so
it's so difficult the Joby got ahead of
them I wouldn't want to do it um well I
would because I probably become like a
millionaire in a couple of months but I
wouldn't really want to do what he's got
ahead of him and I think you know would
sound like a broken record um and I know
I'm coming across very negative I'm just
I am passionate about this and I feel
that there's clear signposts about what
needs to be done and rather than
acknowledging that they they're still
thinking they're living five years ago
when superhero movies were billion
dollar Blockbusters guaranteed and I
just think it's going to lead to more
trouble down the line attaching yourself
to this when there's not the the fan
base are kind of sick of it and that
they're telling you it by the the box
office returns if these movies well
making millions and millions and
millions of dollars then I could totally
understand why you'd want to be attached
to that but I think the the mid reviews
the box office Returns the general love
for the these versions of the heroes in
general you know they're not it's not
there and I think it's a mistake
building it off
that I agree I agree with you
Paul but watch us love Superman Legacy
and Creature Commandos when it comes out
it would be like James gun Our Savior
Jesus gun over here that is yeah that is
my hope and I hope that three years from
now when I'm giving Superman Legacy a 10
out of 10 people clip this on Twitter
and they're like ah but look we found
this old clip of you saying James guns a
slag and we we're playing it to because
you're meeting him tomorrow for an
interview or something he's decided to
bring you along and it was just all to
humiliate me because I've been talking
crap about him um but yeah he might be a
genius this might be the master strategy
that catapults DC ahead of Marvel but
we'll we'll have to see um but yeah I
want to end on a positive note yeah
thanks so much guys for for all your
support these last couple of months um
obviously there's not been that much
news just because of the way the
industry's been we've had kind of a
slower start been more difficult start
wise than I thought uh but you guys have
kept us on obviously there's been way
more people who are in worse situations
than us you know fighting to get paid
fairly and stuff um so congratulations
on this deal which sounds incredible and
also guys as fans we've got so much
stuff to look forward to Loki is gonna
be a blast I promise you that geny from
what I've seen is incredible so
far tonight man
yeah was so busy covering this other
stuff I was like we got a SOA
tonight yeah so yeah lots of stuff to
look forward to hope you guys uh hope
you guys rock ET with us and yeah thanks
a lot for sting through the video make
sure if you're on a podcast service you
you hit a five star rating helps us out
get us all those amazing views and
please subscribe as well and check out
the merch store below if you want to get
some merch Greg's just launching a
soccer t-shirt got my snip she's got
scissors lights scissors
Pap yeah so thanks a lot guys thank you
Greg for joining me again and we'll see
you next week much love